Ці люди моляться за припинення абортів
у своїй сповненій заборонами країні.
Вони - учасники руху "За життя".
Сьогодні вони святкують:
рух "За життя" зібрав мільйон підписів за заборону абортів.
Попри зростання впливу православної церкви на російську політику,
це питання ще не вирішено.
Законодавство, що регулює процедуру, останніми роками посилили,
й депутати обговорюють виключення абортів
із системи обов'язкового медстрахування.
Минулого тижня уряд оголосив про запуск кампанії,
спрямованої на скорочення кількості абортів.
"Ми розуміємо, що для держави вкрай важлива народжуваність.
І тому до держави ми звертаємось саме мовою демографії,
говоримо з нею мовою науки і
ведемо діалог саме з експертної позиції".
Волонтери "За життя" чотири роки збирають підписи.
Рух також займається благодійністю –
підтримує та надає притулок жінкам,
які зважились народжувати.
Однак його учасники вважають,
що влада повинна взагалі не залишити жінками вибору.
"Можна за такою ж аналогією сказати:  давайте скасуємо статтю за вбивство,
і нехай це буде особистий вибір кожної людини.
Тому ми вважаємо, що аборт також має бути законодавчо заборонений".
Нещодавнє незалежне опитування з'ясувало, що тільки два відсотки
росіян підтримують повну заборону абортів.
Не варто забороняти аборти,
тому що люди іноді роблять помилки.
І тоді краще, щоб дитина не народжувалась.
Кожна жінка має сама розпоряджатися своїм тілом,
і буває чимало випадків, коли дитина небажана, особливо в Росії,
коли настільки важка економічна ситуація, коли стільки проблем.
Експерт з репродуктивної медицини Любов Єрофеєва
вважає, що налаштування населення проти абортів
не підвищить рівня народжуваності в Росії.
"Статистика у всіх країнах
світу свідчить
про те, що
ці дані не пов'язані –
забороняючи аборти, ми їх не ліквідуємо,
від них не відмовляться,
їх лише заженуть у підпілля".
У руху "за життя" – небагато прибічників.
Однак вони рішучо налаштовані відстоювати переконання,
що базуються на догматах віри.